hello and welcome to this video Santo
SPG ser tu es PG I don't know so what we
get yeah not be should be seven please I
can go d6 here I tend to automatically
shoot for b5 even though here black can
go for that fee on keto system the damn
I like quite a bit so only quite quite
comfortable to have the fianchetto in
already so what about this now maybe h6
first Tim Bishop g5 publisher be fibers
in the threat so maybe age six wasn't
necessary strictly speaking okay hmm
that's right I was kind of expecting but
should be free after which Knight a5 and
c5 is definitely okay
hmm I carry will go with before next
move and not not quite quite sure how to
play that maybe still is but I guess
before it's a completely ridiculous move
and I'd be a doll so it's making little
sense
hmm I know let's do something creative
oh how can you I don't get it how can
you play c4 after a completely non
standard move like a five and in a split
second that that's really amazing ok
anyway so what's here ok I think I'm
taking him at least I thought a five
would be entirely non-standard you know
this move I I did not pay attention to
him I saw it just a bit too late yeah I
have to speed up here that sets the most
important thing otherwise the position
will madam
yes c5 is an interesting choice but i
think it's a it's a playable one try to
get the night back to c6 and then plug
it to deform he doesn't have his nights
are very far off the d5 square so it
won't be easy for him to get this in I'm
gonna have a form as well Wow
yeah I like this position that seems
very okay 911 some potential for
improvement let's see maybe over to f-86
and so on and it would be fantastic if i
can get my patient rated this is what
i'm trying to do yep I've got that
traded and here he tries maybe to play B
form and so let's put this here
hmm yeah I should have taken okay it's
not a big deal maybe I still should have
taken so night possibly coming to f4 is
trying to prevent that okay I think I'm
stepping back there always sitting in
those checks okay now you still place
those instant moves the very committal
moves instantly age Freud so now i have
aged for coming and it looks pretty
awful so age three or night f4
can also take on f3 by the way it might
work it's very likely to work let's do
this and sacrifice one f3 of him place
Kings you three kings you three hours
every page 8 by the way time working
don't need any fancy moves check
ok check
check isn't there made somewhere I don't
see it Jack hey Jack
check checkmate hmm sorry that wasn't
made yeah yeah I don't know I spent a
spend a bit too much time as I normally
do but i think what what is simply
didn't do around here is so dashing out
move move move and you have to i don't
know i didn't feel it was so simple to
play with this nights is 64 ID I think
white has to be really careful here and
all those moves they they just weakened
why its position yeah maybe it's already
pretty uncomfortable you give you have a
hard time taking the night especially
now as you have played f3 I mean why why
what is night h2 + f3 about I didn't
help why its position at all we came and
I'm here a couple of a couple of ideas
who black but I think getting the tradin
make some sense then improving proving
the night over here at least it kept an
advantage but it got really really
really bad after h4 I think that that
was yeah this is losing right yeah
that's minus 4 yeah with exactly this it
just leads to a losing losing position I
don't know I don't know how can you play
that move anymore in a second this is
what I don't get it's it's it's clear
that this is my movie 3g5 that's super
obvious I mean he has got a decent
writing if he spends like three or four
seconds he might prevent that from
happening until yeah here it's just
toasted 392 okay I could have like 92
yeah that's funny and yeah
yeah okay i was thinking i had a ch3 and
this was my it was the move that I had
anticipated but chan yeah okay it's so
loose again doesn't really matter what's
their meteor Queen age for was also
leading to a mate and then queen f to
check check check check check mate if
you found one mate that's definitely
definitely enough ok well thanks for
watching